the two papers one is by
sinji and colleagues from 2005 and one
is more recent by nulian and colleagues
from 2020
and in both of these studies they used
two grams of spirulina per day as the
treatment dose uh the the earlier study
compared it against placebo and the more
recent study uh compared it against uh
cetera zine which is the generic name
for the brand the brand name drug zyrtec
um
and in in both of these studies like
they looked at a variety of different
endpoints um
which
like
most of them were self-report so it's
like hey how runny is your nose how
itchy is your nose is it more or less
runny or itchy than before um
and and across those kind of
self-reported measures um spirulina
worked pretty well both within group led
to reductions in those nasal allergy
symptoms over time
in the earlier study that compared it
against placebo pretty much washed a
placebo treatment in in virtually
everything which is what you like to see
and in the more recent study that
compared it against uh cetera zine it
did about as well as cetera for a
variety of symptoms and actually
performed better than satirizing for
a few other symptoms which
which is pretty cool from an herbal
supplement um
but yeah overall seems like spirulina
works pretty well in terms of how it
works um
it it seems to reduce the cytokine
response to
things that would tend to cause allergic
symptoms and that is probably downstream
of spirulina blocking histamine release
from mast cells so
um you know what i was i was going to
talk through the biochemical pathways of
allergic reactions a bunch of big words
no one's going to remember it anyway who
cares basically a lot of stuff happens
but one of the first thing that one of
the first things that happens is
like when an allergic response is
triggered is histamine is released from
mast cells that histamine binds to
histamine receptors and then a bunch of
stuff happens downstream of that
including a general inflammatory
response uh part of which is cytokine
release and then you know
you get inflamed you start producing
snot uh the histamine itself sensitizes
nerve cells which is why things feel
itchy like um
a
stimulus that otherwise you wouldn't
even register you wouldn't even feel is
kind of elevated to the point that you
do sense it but you only sense it a
little bit so it's a tickle um so yeah
all of that stuff happens downstream of
histamine release and it seems that
spirulina uh blocks histamine release
and that's a very cool and useful
mechanism of action because that means
at least theoretically it should work
synergistically with like antihistamine
medications so i am currently taking
both spirulina and loratadine which
is that is that allegra i don't know
whatever i just buy the might be
claritin
claritin
who cares i i just buy the generics um
but yeah so i i take loratadine every
allergy season um
and yeah the way that uh antihistamines
tend to work antihistamine medication is
they don't block histamine release what
they do is uh something called
competitive inhibition of the histamine
receptor so if you haven't taken biology
classes or if you haven't taken biology
in a while what competitive inhibition
is is basically you have a molecule that
binds to the same receptor as some other
target molecule
so that's the competitive part the
inhibition part is when it binds to that
receptor it doesn't have an effect
so
basically you have
histamine receptors all over the place
when histamine binds to those receptors
that kind of causes an inflammatory
response downstream to that binding so
antihistamines go in they bind to those
same receptors don't let histamine latch
onto those receptors but when the
antihistamines bind to the histamine
receptor it doesn't cause the same
downstream inflammatory response that
histamines would
so if spirulina actually
blocks some degree of histamine release
um
that shouldn't have any impact on the
efficacy
of antihistamine medications so they
they work via different mechanisms of
action so theoretically they should have
synergistic effects instead of
competitive effects or effects that
might cancel each other out in theory
since they work via different mechanisms
of action if you take both maybe it
would be more effective than just taking
one or the other and in fact that is
what i do